une autre bière bon insecte hé là David
Bowie fait de la place le cow-boy allait
bien boisé assez bien de ce bavardage
il est temps de se mettre au travail boisé
j'ai essayé de te dire garçon que ça
ne te dérangerait pas d'utiliser une partie de tes
gains pour même marquer avec  ton vieil
ami te dit combien tu as besoin j'ai eu un 2020 non
non non non non je pensais plus dans
le sens de disons 10 mille donne lui dix
grand papa
te convaincre de rester est devenu oh
ouais Davey ton père voulait
divorcer parce qu'il baisait un
métis à la réserve il
pensait que c'était amoureux frapper ce bon
esprit
quand était ce bronzage après la naissance de Ross
avant toi tu sais si  J'avais été autour de
vous peut-être même pas ici à l'époque le
divorce était le péché de nos jours je suppose que
c'est bon Dieu devait changer d'avis
vous-même bien que je ne vous ai vraiment pas
blâmé parce que eh bien Kate était
toujours une chienne katell loin de nous je
Je veux que cet argent bouge  d'accord bébé fais comme
tu veux laisse Joe c'est la dernière fois que les
vieux garçons vont jouer gentiment